is the brand new social media app
threads going to kill Twitter as a
YouTube Creator is threads a waste of
your time or an opportunity for you to
grow your brand you know threads reached
30 million users within one day and
eventually reached past a hundred
million users so it would be unwise to
ignore this historic growth and although
my focus is on YouTube I already have
over 19
000 followers on threads and I've
learned a few things so in this video
I'm going to share 12 facts tips and
strategies that you need to know as it
pertains to threads of how to be smart
how to not miss an opportunity but also
how to stay focused and ultimately
approach this platform right today's
episode is brought to you by tube1k
challenge.com but more on that later
let's get into number one which is sign
up for Threads and secure your handle so
threads is a brand new platform launched
by meta who now owns Facebook and
Instagram and threads it's clearly a
copy or a direct competitor to Twitter
it's causing all kinds of drama whereas
uh Twitter's already launched a lawsuit
against meta in regards to this but
nevertheless the growth is incredibly
fast and minimum I would suggest that
you sign up for Threads and secure your
handle now the interesting thing about
this new social media platform is that
it's connected to your Instagram so if
you already have an Instagram you just
go into your app store for Android or
iPhone download the threads app and then
they pretty much link up it's pretty
chill and if anything you could just
come back to this later you have to go
he could post like one thread you could
just get it set up I'm not sure if
someone would be allowed to steal your
handle because if they didn't steal your
handle on Instagram this is assuming you
have an Instagram then I don't think
there's a way to change your name on
threads I'm not sure but tip for any
social media platform secure the bag
secure your handle on the platforms
you're not even active on because who
knows someday you may want to be active
there and fortune favors the fast number
two leverage the threads Instagram
integration because threads integrates
with Instagram not only can you link
your accounts but you also can sync your
bio in your profile picture so it all
happens pretty much instantly you also
can transfer your verification so if you
are verified on Instagram or paying for
the advanced features to get that blue
check and some of the other things that
transfers over which is um kind of a
cool feature the streamlinedness of it
all is what I think has made it
attractive to so many people that are
active on Instagram threads also
provides an instant built-in Community
for users giving you the option to
follow everyone that you already follow
on Instagram so it makes it easier to
grow your following quickly a big key if
you are active on Instagram and if you
have any following whatsoever on
Instagram I think it makes sense to be a
part of threads
if you have never started an Instagram
then this whole thing might you know be
a waste of your time for the season
you're in at this moment
um you already haven't secured your
handle on IG you already haven't you
know gone down that path but I know a
lot of people in the think media podcast
Community are already active on
Instagram it may be one of your main
platforms to socialize and share and
jump in the DMS and do all kinds of
stuff so the fact they're integrated
that is a big Advantage so growing on
threads is easier if you have an
existing following on Instagram as
followers on Instagram automatically
join threads and notifications are sent
to followers when someone they follow
joins threads now I'll hit this later
but also the fact that these are
connected makes it easy to for example
post a thread which is text based or
photo based or image based and then
share that as an Instagram profile post
or story so threads is not like starting
from scratch nowhere near close to that
their star starting with the full force
of meta Facebook behind them all of
those developers all that infrastructure
and all of that integration number three
take some time after you've signed up to
explore the app and understand the
culture
so different platforms have different
cultures they have a different vibe they
have a different dress code you address
one way if you go to In and Out Burger
on the west coast you dressed another
way if you went to a five-star
restaurant at the Four Seasons you're
gonna be in you know suit jacket you're
going to be in a ball gown whereas at in
and out you might be in flip-flops and
tank tops so different different apps
have different cultures one of the
things at least initially and at the
time of recording this podcast threads
is like a week old it's pretty young so
so it'll change but threads definitely
has a different culture compared to
Twitter it's focusing more on
um raw organic positive at this point
because there's not any Bots there
there's not a lot of trolls or spam or
anything like that there and they are
discouraging politics and hard news
whereas Twitter is kind of like a news
first platform trending hashtags
trending headlines to Twitter I like
Twitter for news whereas threads is more
like let's go hang with the homies and
right now it's kind of like this pop-up
party
that has a lot of energy from being
brand new the other thing is it's a
really a non-marketing environment and
meta has said that they are not going to
even allow monetization people to pay
for ads like you can pay for ads to
advertise on Instagram or Facebook until
a billion users on threads which would
be like over double Twitter's entire
user base so the big question is will
threads continue to rise will the buzz
burn off or will it surpass Twitter's
growth because of the fact that
Facebook's got like three billion users
Instagram's got like 2.5 Twitter's got
like 300 million so we'll see where it
all goes but nevertheless number three
is take some time to explore the app and
understand the culture number four
out of 12 tips facts and strategies
regarding jumping on threads should you
is it worth it number four post engaging
content that is share Worthy
so that's kind of a universal tip but
the the what do I share on threads well
number five stick to a niche stick to a
niche so you should already if you're
listening to the think media podcast you
should already be
clear about who who it is you serve what
problem do you solve if you aren't you
got to go to
findyourtopic.com and watch that class
because like knowing who what you're
even doing online what problem you solve
what is your money plan what's the
bigger Vision what's what are you
actually building what value do you
provide to people is it education or
entertainment all of that kind of stuff
so if number five you stick to a niche
to Growing threads it's recommended to
have a niche a reason to people follow
you a specific area of expertise you
might say Sean that's easy for you to
say because you're the YouTube guy
you're the author of YouTube secrets
well yeah it is easy for me to say
because I jump on threads and it's like
well how do you know what to post what I
always post tips on YouTube tips on
online video tips for Branding tips for
personal branding related to online
video tech maybe Prime day just happened
all that kind of stuff
and then a little bit of Lifestyle
because there's relational a little bit
of I share my faith a few things about
just leadership stuff I'm passionate
about I ask questions I'm engaging but
but I know my Niche what's yours so
number five stick to your Niche I know
I'm jumping backwards number four post
engaging content that's share worthy but
ideally you want to post engaging
content that's share worthy related to
your area of expertise topics and text
content around your
niche and the cool thing is engagement
is up if only for the start and we'll
see how this plays out and I'll get to
some points later to well what if it
ends up failing in the end well who
knows but what are you gonna do to sit
there on the sidelines and watch here's
the fact of the moment engagement is up
it's been wild to test the difference
between Twitter where some people are
disillusioned with Twitter engagement's
going down on Twitter there's a lot of
noise on Twitter some people love
Twitter a lot of people hate Twitter
here's the fact threads engagement is
pretty wild because people are are over
their partying they're there they're um
and it's brand new
there's less people there than anywhere
the algorithm is trying to provide a
great experience for you
and others using it so there's a lot of
reasons engagement is up
so fortune favors the fast if you move
fast there's some opportunities there so
number four post engaging content that's
share worthy number five stick to a
niche number six wisely repurpose
content on threads keyword wisely
so I think one of the biggest mistakes
you can make is just indiscriminately
repurposing content across social media
like you're just a robot like there's no
heart to it there's no soul to it
however
there's I went to like my Twitter
and I go to my analytics and I look at
some of the best posts text based and
I'm like cool there's some content and
I'll drop that on threads now I'm not
just doing it in a row I'm humanly going
to look at things that I've taken put my
heart energy into writing lessons I've
learned and I've tested that it's it's
worked elsewhere it's worked on Twitter
text posts have worked on Facebook text
posts have worked on the YouTube
Community tab so
always trying to come up with an
original idea man I'm under slept I'm
trying to take care of these two and a
half year old and this nine-year-old
trying to sip enough coffee it's kind of
hard to get something great out of my
brain I want to leverage something
that maybe I've already written it's
it's something I've written something
that is somewhere else why not share
that on threads so wisely just means
you're doing it intentionally you're
being thoughtful so you could repurpose
your best content from Twitter Facebook
Instagram captions onto threads and that
could be an effective strategy to
creating some engaging content a little
bit easier and what I'm doing is and and
by the way if you want to kind of look
at my threads history at Sean Cannell is
the same as
um Instagram Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel on the video version of
this podcast you can see it in the lower
right hand corner
um I'm over there on threads and I'm
asking questions in between and engaging
with other people and then going deep
and so
wisely number six repurpose content on
threads number seven
start conversations and answer questions
so an opportunity here is to ask genuine
questions have genuine conversations and
engage with other users these are key
strategies to creating dialogue that
builds connections on threads
and what I've learned is
that um at this moment especially it's
it's pretty cool it's because it's like
this is what you know for sure this is
um what's exciting about a new platform
is if there's no Bots there yet and
there's no
like people have followed you over the
last seven years but they they stopped
engaging they followed you but then they
deleted their account they followed you
and you know something's happened where
they're no longer there so you're like
okay I have amassed a certain number of
followers or subscribers but that
doesn't mean like the engagement's
really there and like they're actually
you know engaged active whereas when a
platform is brand new
there's a whole other level of energy
and real humans on the other side of
like every interaction even when I
started a new YouTube channel the think
media podcast Channel
it's very blessed to have over a hundred
thousand subscribers but it's wild that
the engagement in a lot of ways is
better than my 2 million subscriber
Channel because that one's 10 years old
and it has a lot of different topics
we've talked about and lessons we've
learned and people that have you know as
crazy as the sounds there's probably
subscribers that are subscribed to think
media that are actually dead
you didn't expect me to go there but you
know what I mean like it's kind of weird
you're like over like Unfortunately they
subscribed and they've passed away
they've you know and it's going to be
hard for a dead person to you know
comment back and engage with you and so
ultimately when you have a brand new
platform there's like a freshness
whereas basically every follower and I
know it's integrated with Instagram but
basically every follower basically every
new subscriber on our new YouTube
channel
is choosing to do so in a shorter window
of time all that to say is that the
conversations are legit it's a really
great place to have some really engaging
um dialogue and this is a big
opportunity so for the YouTube creator
why would I use this well is it going to
help you grow your YouTube channel not
necessarily but it is going to help you
go deeper with people who already care
about what it is you're doing
if people have chosen to follow you on
Instagram and then they connect over
with you on threads that just very May
will be the place where
they ultimately uh start something where
you were kind of a surface relationship
to them or they sort of forgot about you
and here's what I've been seeing which
is really cool threads is
it's a Revival of people I haven't
connected with in years
it is uh a lot of people that are being
kind of surfaced to the top that the
Instagram algorithm which is now full of
not the people you really follow but
mainly vertical videos of like whatever
you like kittens snowboarding you know
it's like all reels of stuff that's just
like fashion weird cap cut edits and
like a bunch of stuff it's not even the
people you follow and Facebook is all
this sponsored posts and all this stuff
you barely see your family members posts
you know all these algorithms Twitter's
got all kinds of whatever going why am I
being shown what I'm being shown what's
happening on threads right now is like a
big party
it's like a big family reunion
potentially and like like hey bro I
haven't seen you in a long time like
yeah we're connected on Instagram but
like I haven't actually seen you like
the the school got too big like the you
know the business got too big we don't
run into each other at the water cooler
anymore like what what's happening right
now on threads is like people running to
each other at the water cooler new
connections but also maybe old people
from years depending on how long you've
been on social media that you can start
conversations answer questions and have
authentic dialogue number eight
it is a text-based platform like Twitter
it's primarily focused on text-based
content but number eight you also can
post images videos and links and so
couple things I've noticed one images
pretty cool similar to anywhere just
drop an image I've done stuff with a
little bit of family stuff I have posted
to a YouTube video I uploaded the
thumbnail and I posted the link to the
YouTube video and what I love about this
is that workflow like clicking a link to
a YouTube video so clean it did not
really it just took you straight to the
YouTube app it didn't like give you four
different blocks like are you sure you
want to leave the platform you're like
yes then it opens it up inside of
threads and you're not even logged in
and you're super frustrated and like
links perform incredibly well it's a
clean very simple very basic place right
now it's one of the downsides some
people are saying is it lacks 99 of the
features that Twitter has what makes
sense because When developing software
it takes time to build out features
build out different Dynamics key
is you can share images you could share
links I don't recommend just linking to
stuff but if you're engaging in
dialoguing and conversing why not also
add more value and well here's what I've
also seen is if you've got good valuable
videos in your library
already related to your expertise
expertise your profession if you start
conversations one of my favorite things
to do is like you know how do you need
help on YouTube or what are you
struggling with someone might say I'm
struggling with this then I think I've
got a video on that so I go hey I think
this will help and I link one person to
one video I don't think enough people
think about social media that way you're
posted videos on YouTube hoping you go
viral when what you should be doing is
not just that but like making
one-on-one connections on social media
with people and then personally sharing
with them a video that answers their
specific question helps them with their
specific pain Point not in a spammy way
in a personal way like very much you
know they go I'm not sure like one of
the videos we did was uh that I did was
you know when to quit and when to Pivot
and it was based on the dip it's oh
we'll link it up in the show notes of
this podcast it's a very powerful
episode because sometimes people are
frustrated you've been doing YouTube for
one two three years it hasn't broken
through
should you quit should you pivot when's
the right time what are the questions to
assess that so that came up on threads
so I linked to that video especially
because I couldn't really respond
uh with all the nuances in text but I've
got a video for that and hopefully the
user on the other side personally was
handed a video by me
that in a relational context never
underestimate the power of what you
could do for one person rather than
focusing on trying to get a million
views think about making one meaningful
connection at a time I think threads is
an opportunity to do that right now
and if you've got a video in your
library rather than just blanketly being
like go watch my video I'm talking about
start conversations as you discern
people's pain points then personally
share a video with them what's one view
worth not much in YouTube ad Revenue but
everything as it pertains to serving
someone connecting with a human really
adding value and having things be
personalized and then when it comes to I
think it's like a 500 character limit on
text you know you could post a photo
videos I think could be five minutes and
this was one of my favorite things I
used to do all the time on Twitter
is also if you're doing Q a we're asking
how you can serve people or you want to
respond to somebody you can respond with
video the way that I do it was I just
recorded a one to two minute answer
right on my phone it's then saved in my
iPhone library and then I click reply
and I click the little paper clip and I
say add video and then my response if I
couldn't think of a concise way to say
it in text I then shared a link to that
video or just uploads right to threads
and talk about again personalized
connection
so if you're in real estate you could
say hey what what questions you have
about buying a house right now answer
one person with one question share a
video you know share some text share a
video from your library and the fact
that you can again upload videos is
another option so number eight is
leverage images leverage videos leverage
links leverage text
number nine connect reconnect and build
community so I kind of already touched
this one connect with people reconnect
you'll be surprised depending on how
active you are on social you'll be
shocked how many people kind of
resurface and again it's going to be a
smaller number than your Instagram
followers because not everyone will move
to threads or has moved to threads but
those who have made the intentional
decision to do that to do so so that's
why it's a legit party because like
everybody who's walked into the threads
mansion
is actually there like ready to talk and
connect and you know intentional about
it so there's a chance to connect with
new people reconnect with old people
refresh the relationship and build
community number 10 use this moment to
reach out to hard to reach people
so first movers Advantage one of the
things that mistakes people make is they
wait on the sidelines for too long there
is something about not getting crazy
distracted and like ignoring your
priorities but using a little bit of
your r d time your research and
development time your extra time
to uh you know get out there and network
a little bit and maybe you wanted to
have somebody on your show reach out to
them on threads maybe it's too noisy on
Twitter they're not over there their DMS
are too full on Instagram general or
primary their DMS on Facebook they
haven't been there in a while their
email inbox is innovated so let's say
you wanted to collab with somebody
interview somebody reach out to somebody
connect with somebody this is definitely
the moment to do that if that person's
on threads and again you're not just
going some hard spam Hard Sell you're
you're creating genuine connections
Gary vaynerchuk talks about like his
dollar eighty rule which is leave your
two cents so I don't know why it's a
dollar eighty but go do that to a
hundred people's accounts if you want to
really connect and build even a
following on a new platform well you
might say well Sean I'm I'm at zero how
can I grow from zero well in your Niche
all the way back to number five stick to
a niche no no your Zone know your know
your lane
like me doing video
um I could debate I could jump into
conversations about the new Sony a6700
versus the FX series and and share my
take I can jump into conversations about
social media I could jump into some
conversations about running a small
business and not just like dropping a
fire Emoji or something but actually
share your two cents your meaningful two
cents and when somebody sees your
thought leadership your point of view
your take or they see your thoughtful
kindness and response and appreciation
that can lead to Serious connections so
use this moment number 10 to reach out
to hard to reach people
and
also use this moment to again not just
post but Converse go throughout threads
maybe there's people you want to build a
relationship deeper with
um my favorite form of networking is not
some weird transaction based thing it's
just like the constant farming of
investing in relationships with no
expectations but knowing that good
things happen when you cultivate and you
build relationships not because you want
something because you're just like man
this person's cool like maybe someday
like I've got an event grow a video live
by the way get on the waitlist grow with
video live.com it's coming back 2024
and last year we had garyvee and Alex
hermosi and Patrick David speak there
and maybe you think about characters
like that you'd be like man I can't even
imagine ever ever doing something with
them well the the idea would be to
cultivate relationships with those
individuals even over years if possible
and how do you do that well one of the
ways would be to be just showing up in a
meaningful way and at different touch
points not to have like some weird pushy
transactional mindset but just have an
investment mindset and again when threat
when something new like threads is not
noisy at all it's it's hot there's a lot
of Engagement happening but it's not
noisy in terms of ads nothing happened
on the side it's a stripped down version
1.0 type of an app
this could be the time that you could
reach out to hard to reach people maybe
it's a Biz partner a collab somebody
you've always I was just on someone's
show and they literally told me too they
said we have tried to reach you
we've probably sent you 55 messages on
LinkedIn DMS which is a good point
because I'm like guess what I saw Zero
of those I'm sorry I'm busy no excuse I
just I'm not really in my LinkedIn DMS
get it so your point could be maybe
there's somebody you've always wanted to
connect with this could be your moment
number 11. out of 12 avoid cynicism
negativity and headline reading so if
you already made it this far you're
clearly curious and and considering that
it could be worth your time to test out
threads
but what's unfortunate with a lot of
people is they just go oh this is so
dumb we don't need another social media
platform oh this is just a copy of
Twitter oh this is just gonna fail
Mark's Dom elon's dumb just some
billionaires that are going to fight in
the UFC this is dumb okay until it isn't
like you could be right
but also you might be wrong
and you also probably haven't really
done research you may have just read
headlines
and I think that honestly cynicism
and negativity and headline reading is
is ultimately not helpful now you got to
do you so if you're like listen my biz
is good my YouTube channel is good my
income's good
there's no one I want to reach out to
and I don't really want to go deeper
with my community and you know I'm busy
enough for right now well fine if you
really are self-aware and and calmly
thoughtfully making smart strategic
decisions for yourself and your business
I wouldn't that's the only thing I would
ever encourage but but a lot of people
they just get really cynical and and
just jump to Quick conclusions When
jumping to any concrete conclusions it's
way too early in the game to do that so
like the future is ultimately uncertain
is Twitter gonna die I don't think so
but maybe it goes down by a death of a
million Cuts if it keeps offending
people or keeps having like the they're
doing stuff like the um
uh there's issues with ads there's bot
accounts they're limiting viewing limits
like how many tweets you could do in a
day paid verification
a lot of people have negative sentiment
towards Twitter but that could turn
around
Twitter could go down and then you'll be
really grateful that you didn't just
like sync with the Titanic but you
Diversified a little bit and got on the
threads there's a lot of different
Futures so I think it's smart to just be
thoughtful about okay what move could I
make here
and so this is your choice you could
risk nothing and gain nothing
or you could jump in and create a first
mover's advantage
so you know Twitter has been
experiencing a decline in engagement and
user satisfaction over the past few
years there is some negative perception
there
and
the The Limited daily tweet views and
the prevalence of bots and sometimes
maybe how even toxic it can feel
some people are like I love the Good
Vibes of threads and it also feels more
human and but who knows
so there is nothing and gain nothing or
jump in and create a first mover's
Advantage for this sophisticated content
creator business owner it's a little bit
further along there's no reason you
can't be in both places how can I be
there well I've got a team supporting me
meaning
I've got editing outsourced you know
I've got thumbnails help and Outsource
now I've got a lot of the description a
lot of the operations of customer
service there's a lot of there's a whole
team
so I'm intentional as a leader to buy
back my time so that I can test and
experiment
and invest in something like this I'm
not going crazy but I'm I've spent a
significant amount of time over there so
I could even make an episode like this
I've tested it I've tried it you want to
avoid reading headlines from people who
haven't even
jumped in and used the dang platform
it's funny how how much like somebody
doesn't even have a threads account and
they got an opinion on it they haven't
even spent one two three four five ten
hours you know it's only been a couple
weeks so like maximum you I made a joke
too I made a joke post where I said uh
my new threads ebook was coming out it
really confused about half the people
they were like and I was like this has
been the hardest three years this has
taken me three years to go in this
project 10 000 hours I'm so proud of the
result how to be how to monetize like a
boss on threads and people were like
how could you have spent three years
it's only been out for 24 hours I was
like it's a joke bro it was
it's a joke and then other people were
like you're lying I'm like well yeah I
mean that's it's just trying to it's
trying to be funny clearly I wasn't I'm
I apologize I'm just you know dad jokes
over here and so
um all that to say is people can have
opinions and they haven't even really
done their research they haven't checked
things out you know one of the deeper
things that is also could be very
interesting here is this activity Pub
Pub integration
so
activity Pub without going into it this
is kind of a whole like most people
don't know about this
activity Pub integration and threads
allows interaction between Instagram
threads Instagram threads and other
platforms like Mastodon
it's a whole nother can of worms so it
potentially is benefiting an open
internet and experts are saying we're
actually resetting the internet right
now moving into a new era where
essentially
we might step into a social media world
where your followers could pop up
anywhere like the followers like maybe
Mark will keep Mark Zuckerberg will keep
opening new platforms that have
different features but you can carry
your Instagram following to to threads
to platform X to platform Y and people
that don't even have that platform can
still interact with you this might be
kind of mind-numbing and you're saying
Sean what are you even saying what I'm
saying is there's something deeper than
the headlines what most people aren't
seeing
is they're like oh this is just a this
is just a dumb copy this is just this
this is just that everyone has like that
really shallow view of things
this activity Pub integration
could really be a game changer and it
doesn't mean like threads is going to be
the future but activity Pub and this
kind of like open internet
I forget they call it like the
threativerse or something like that and
it's this idea that again you kind of
can carry with you your followers your
identity across platforms so you don't
have to just build up another platform
from scratch and that some people have
criticized threads again oh the only
reason it grew is because it's growing
on the back of Instagram
yeah I mean probably true but that does
that mean it's bad
and what are the implications of that
you know what are the opportunities
of that and so all that to say
11 avoid cynicism avoid negativity avoid
headline reading do some research do
some testing risk nothing gain nothing
and potentially maybe create a place
where again for the YouTube Creator
YouTube's got to be your focus I really
believe that and you got to focus on
your ipas your income producing
activities but
people do business with people they know
like and trust and the people the the
creators who win the future are going to
be creators who build community
and so
when it's a one-way conversation of
someone just watching a video ensure
they can leave a comment
that doesn't even come close to a
two-way conversation that could go down
in a place like threads
and remember if you've been listening to
the think media podcast for any length
of time then you know that all you need
is a thousand true fans
and so what would happen if one person
at a time one relationship at a time one
conversation at a time you built your
way up to a thousand true fans
it could change everything it could help
you go full time I'm not I'm not trying
to oversell or get you distracted by
threads but I am trying to attack in my
opinion some of the shallow negativity
and cynicism and headline reading that
hasn't looked underneath the surface of
how big this could be
or maybe it won't
but no risk no reward we'll get to
number 12 in just a second
but
um I do want to invite you if you
haven't registered to register at
tube1kchallenge.com for our next five
day YouTube challenge here's the fact
you already know that Sean is it twed's
is it threads or is it Twitter it's
YouTube you know is it Facebook or is it
Instagram it's YouTube so YouTube is Far
and Away
the leader and the place that you should
establish your content your intellectual
property your show your video podcast
YouTube is the place these other
platforms are are cool but like they
orbit around the center of the universe
YouTube and then you've got Pluto sad
it's not even a planet anymore you've
got you know these other platforms
um that are orbiting the Sun but really
I really believe it YouTube is is the
Hub it's the home base it is the number
one place to be building your brand and
saying that if you want to start or grow
or trigger growth then definitely
register for our free five-day challenge
tube1kchallenge.com it's five days long
five sessions totally free you're gonna
be learning from myself we have some
special guests and it's all about how to
get your first or next a thousand
subscribers in multiple different ways
to set up passive income streams from
YouTube and some of the latest stuff
that's working right now
so check that out and that is starting
soon and then brings us to number 12
which is focus and keep your priorities
straight
so I really believe in like the 80 20
principle and in this context I mean it
like this
I would focus 80 percent
of your time on your income producing
activities and on your highest impact
priorities so YouTube would be that it'd
be like okay am I getting my video
podcast out am I getting my videos am I
ranking my videos am I connecting am I
creating search based videos connected
to passive income streams is my money
right my business right my brand right
am I investing in long-term things am I
investing in the fact that I can make a
video today on YouTube and it'll pay me
tomorrow and a year from now and five
years from now
if I've done that am I 80 of my time
twenty percent of your time could be
research and development
so focus and keep your priorities
straight Sean are you saying threads
should be your number one priority far
from it like I'm not I'm not even not
even close in the conversation I just
think it is and I wanted to do this
episode I think it's relevant to talk
about I don't think it should just be
thrown out and I don't think it's dumb I
think it's legit and it could be
interesting time will tell
but you got to be willing you know the r
d Department of a business is willing to
have experiments fail
the research and development department
is willing to invest time money and
energy even if it doesn't succeed
because what they realize is like Thomas
Edison I tried ten thousand ways that
didn't work to find the one that did
so will threads fail maybe but what if
it becomes the new king and you get in
early that's just your r d time you
don't just drop everything when you're
experimenting it would be too early to
do that wisely because we're unsure
people made that mistake with Clubhouse
I don't regret all the time I spent on
clubhouse right you might not even
remember Clubhouse but I I met people
I've met people in person since then
since the clubhouse days many in fact
I've talked to people that are like oh
you know we had a conversation on
clubhouse so even though that platform
is gone we it was still about forward
progress but I'm okay if some of my
experiments fail that's my 20 of my
research and development time but focus
and keep your priorities straight and so
know that the same summation of this
episode is I do think you should dip
your toes in the threads ocean claim
your profile you know they they were
rewarding people that got in it
under a million now under 10 million and
the number with which you join becomes a
link underneath your Instagram profile
creates a little bit of fomo there's
some smart things they're doing with the
launch but keep your priorities straight
I think you dip your toast in there but
you know subscribe if you're not
subscribed like this episode or rate and
review depending on where you're
listening to the think media podcast and
the future is forward and the future is
YouTube but these other platforms they
are some support platforms that I think
can do some interesting things and
that's my take on threads what's your
take if you're on the YouTube video I'm
curious let me know in the comments do
you like it do you hate it have you
started it if you want to connect with
me on threads at Sean Cannell but the
one thing to do is make sure to join us
for the tube1kchallenge.com I'll see you
in the next think media podcast